DEVILS, HOPING TO INSULATE SEE N
OVER THE COLORADO LINE, BASTIAN
WITH THE DROP, EASAS IT VERYMID
SCORE!
MacKINNON TOOOO NATHAN
MacKINNON HAS HE JUST GETS A
PL
AND THERE'S RANTANEN, I DON'T
KNOW IF HEHE TONIGHT, BUT KYLE
CENTER.
FINAL 17 SECONDS INOCTANE OFFEN
BUT THEYND.
IT WAS THE
STICK OF PAVEL ZACAC UP SIEGENT
OFF THE POST, THEY SCORE IN A A
AS KICKING MOTION, WE'LL SUPPOR
HUGHES, HUGHES, FLYING IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE, BACKHAND,
FOL
FOLLOWED BLOCKED BY CATALYST
AGAIN, THAT SKATING ABILITY ASE.
WE AREO SEVERSON AND
THIS IS A BLAST.
KIND OFLY, BIG SAVE
BY
TATAR TO FREE UP THE PUCK, OFF
TO THE
>>> TRANSITION, FINDS GRAVES,
JOINING THE ATTACK, ANDET THEM
BACK INTO PLAY.
>> Steve: BACK
RETURN FROM SEVERSON AGAIN
REDIRECTED AND THEYBLOCKED, THE
INITIAL SHOT OF HUGHES BY THE
GOAL SCRAMBLE
FOR THE PUCK SCORES!
>> Ken: E A SAVE,
THEY CLEAR IT ONCE THERE AND
THENEN